les yvelines bon élève de la couverture
vaccinale contre la grippe sur la saison
dernière 46 5% des personnes invitées à
se faire vacciner ont eu recours à la
vaccination contre 44,5 pour cent en
2014 2015 une progression causés par les
mesures des pouvoirs publics tant que
l'assurance maladie a adressé dans les
yvelines un bon de prise en charge à 245
milles personnes pour les inciter à se
faire vacciner en retirant gratuitement
le vaccin dans les pharmacies à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la couverture
vaccinale a reculé cinq communes ont un
taux de couverture en dessous de 45 %
pour ces situations la cpam des yvelines
travail avec la rs et les acteurs locaux
avec comme objectif travailler sur un
diagnostic départementale donc sur les
vaccinations notamment la vaccination
grippe mais aussi les vaccinations
petite enfance et sur la base d'un
diagnostic cartographier de menthe et de
mettre en place un plan d'action
départemental pour améliorer la
couverture vaccinale en 2015 2016 près
de 2500 consultation sos médecins ont
été causés par des syndromes grippaux
dans les yvelines selon les données de
santé publique france contre environ
3000 en 2014 2015
il faut savoir que le plus souvent les
symptômes de la grippe apparaissent 1 à
3 jours après la contamination est forte
fièvre fatigue courbatures maux de tête
sont les premiers signes de la maladie
si pour la plupart des personnes la
guérison se fait spontanément pour
d'autres la grippe peut se compliquer et
entraîné une hospitalisation en
réanimation voir un décès les personnes
âgées de 65 ans et plus et celles
présentant des facteurs de risque qu'il
s'agisse d'une grossesse d'une maladie
chronique
ça peut être affections respiratoires
cardiovasculaires immunodépression
diabète et les personnes obèses
voilà pour les principaux sujets à
risque devaient se laver les mains et se
protéger la bouche en cas d'éternuement
ou de toux sont d'autres moyens de
lutter contre la propagation du virus de
la grippe
pas